crédible merci merci dites allez je
me lance dans des trucs de camée c'est un vrai
visionnaire il nous a appris non seulement à
faire face aux défis d'aujourd'hui mais il nous a
aussi appris comment se préparer
pour la proposition de demain voir la favela
Lutz Allie Miguelito a un nouveau  minimum
de la réforme Réconciliation démocratique
faveur de la guitarra un climatique c'est un un
trophée un nom classique cette forme forme
jeter ce retour rouler ce retour laissez-moi le
faire encore c'est trop important
non je monte juste un peu en fait
désolé c'est conservateur à a a  trophée a sa
forme merci beaucoup de merci
merci beaucoup
abdos vous ABN soo-ji assumer en regardant en arrière
de Levante Hall a dit bien sûr une nouvelle d'une
importance parallèle le PM composé le
Québec le papa dit d'accord pourquoi K
parce que dans l'image politique hors pitié  clé
merci beaucoup merci
[Applaudissements]